okay so I said we're going to come back
to this idea of a network operating
system okay
what's a network operating system well
maybe we should answer the question
let's go back to a different color now
what is an operating system if someone
had never seen a computer before how
would you describe the operating system
to do hmm you said your operating system
is the hmm is the what well the first
thing we can say right is it K it comes
under um it comes under this heading
software right so let's start off our
definition by saying an operating system
is a piece of software that piece of
software that what yeah
okay let's say the populace is yours
first and then we'll try and put it
together is it anything different
okay all right
um that's okay it accesses it provides
access to the hardware right so you know
you and me we can't um we can't move
around the you know the the head the
magnetic head inside the hard drive and
read the data we can't do that with none
of the skills or the you know manual
dexterity to do that okay so provides
access to the hardware right and it also
allows us to move on other kinds of
software that can do stuff to it for us
right provides access to hardware and I
suppose you can take a platform it's
like what all the other software the
application software sort of stands upon
and then you can use it you know these
were these days we call those
abstraction or fabrications okay now
this is a really crucial relationship
that you need to get so an operating
system is sometimes called middleware
it'll where to stand in the middle of
the hardware which is what does the job
and these applications software which
actually do the things that you want
because no one gets on the computer and
I'm says hey I really want to use
Windows today I mean I hope you don't
that's kind of a settlor you know the
questions you might get that is ah I
think I'm gonna play some solitaire or
something a minesweeper right
but even then come in this is cool
morning four o'clock yeah it's right
thank you let's get going
you don't really try to access the
applications yes they're the things are
you really more okay now if that's what
an operating system is what's a network
operating system why do we need a
special kind of operating system to let
us live on a network okay
well I'll show you two pictures to try
to illustrate why special kinds of
operating systems are required for you
to actually get onto a network to access
all this different stuff okay so here my
pictures okay so what's this this is a
street a road and it's out in where
where does it look like it looks like it
I heard that that's very nice I guess
okay well that sure look again right so
that tells me nothing
well it looks like we're in the bush
somewhere somewhere rural okay actually
I found this by searching up rural rural
Street okay now just look at it okay as
well as a road it doesn't need too much
to it right it just needs to be flat
enough and wide enough to fit cars on it
yeah okay so here's like a kind of
operating system it'll let applications
cars run on it okay but if you want to
provide access to a whole bunch of other
things and network right your road is
going to have to change a little bit
right so this is what I think of as a
network operating system as opposed to a
regular operating system if all you want
to do is just do your own thing but your
own one node doing your own applications
and not having it interact with others
you can be relatively simple but when
you introduce other people into the mix
right you need more lanes you need
markings you need bus only places you
need things that tell pedestrians when
to go and when to stop you need traffic
lights right you see all of this extra
infrastructure
is required because well when you get
checked with other people you need more
rules you need the protocols okay and
that's what the network operating system
provides so a network operating system
it sort of enables you to access all
this stuff it also enables
administrators this is an important
stuff being right users can access right
sorry to SM right but it also enables
administrators some sense of control you
sort of need both of these control
sounds very arm right - at a latarian
and like yeah I'll stick it to the man
but actually when you have no control
there's no useful access can you imagine
what you know this street would look
like if there was no sense of control
over that just there was a wild wild
west
they'll just be crashes everywhere no
one would actually be able to get to
anything right and probably people would
get killed along the way so there needs
to be some sense of control in order to
help the users get access to all of this
stuff okay all right now I was going to
go a bit further but I think looking at
the time and because of the presentation
we did I'm just going to finish out here
and we'll leave the rest of this file
later on okay so last little hang for
today Network policies
okay so here's what we had to start with
resources and then go to operating
systems and now look at policies well
what's a policy what do you think I want
your policy privacy policy
what's a privacy policy ah it's a set of
rules that tell you what you can expect
what kind of rights you have that kind
of thing okay so in a network network
policies are about assigning particular
groups particular rights rights to what
you might ask anyone got any guesses
think about what we've looked at this
money yeah what an actual non textbook
response so then put that together in
one phrase right so particular groups
particular rights to UM network
resources right so these resources
they're so useful they're really good
but if you just let anyone take whatever
they want it's not going to be useful
for everyone is it it's just going to be
a total mess it'll be chaos okay so you
know when you come back up here all this
stuff see if you use hundreds and
thousands of them right well that
everyone could just grab them and take
that processing power for whatever they
want then you know you feel like a dr.
evil on your hands right his own world
domination or whatever in the same way
printers you know for instance is going
to be local access only certain people
can printer certain printers and you
know it's definitely in everyone's
interests in terms of privacy right but
not everyone has access to all the CCTV
footage right in fact as far as I know
there's only a single computer that has
a single user on that computer that has
permission to access this particular
Network resource okay so this is kind of
like if you like um the the synonym I
have my head it's a kind of government
right oops Govan which is probably a
good analogy because when I think of
policies I think of politicians as well
because they're the people who set
policy yes